[Applause]
and Thompson grants has left me now
writhing in pain Steph Curry slamming
the bowl on the court so upset Green
went up to block it some of the players
saying something Danny Green saying I'm
just trying to block the play that
wasn't a dirty play by Danny Green
everybody for the Warriors in the
franchise to narrow the stands holding
their breath
plate tops and obviously in some pain he
grabbed that left knee right away
mark you talked about it earlier one of
his strengths is adorable he's been fact
that he only missed the one game after
straining the hamstring he plays on a
lot of nights other players wouldn't be
out there and I'm gonna say this they're
gonna be more wary of putting him back
in there you see the awkward landing and
right away after this Durant situation
Wow
so obviously needs help up the ante
Greece just trying to block that shot
that that as you said Jeff it's not a
dirty play as soon as Thompson grip that
this is what Steph Curry was doing and
Mike if he leaves he can't come back in
so if he doesn't shoot the free throws
he's out for the rest of the game
[Applause]
wait klay Thompson is headed back to the
locker room but then turned around and
lived back out on the floor and is what
Jeff you said on a personal foul as
Danny Green
Joseph sportsmanship there and Thompson
agrees there was nothing intentional but
if you're hurt on a play and it's not a
flagrant foul and you can't shoot the
free throws you cannot return to the
game and I think they got the message to
klay Thompson as it was walking back the
locker room hey if you want to come back
in this game you need to shoot these
free throws and if you're Steve Kerr you
substitute right now so that when you
take the foul as you see playing in the
back he was walking to the locker room
and then somebody yelled something he
turns around to shoot the free throws
then you can take him out obviously and
got the huge roar from the Oracle cloud
there is similar to the Boston
experience of Paul Pierce when he came
back onto the floor but the difference
is this guy didn't have to use the
restroom and he hits the free-throw
you can still see him dragging that
right leg a little bit more than me
excuse me as he now has 29 points and
I'm not sure they're gonna foul I think
they're signaling for to go back in
place don't to me I'm committing the
foul but play Thompson looked like he
can actually actually survive on the
floor right now
he's staying in the game and there's the
foul cousin Stiles siakam Thompson did
not want to come out they didn't want
that foul and cook will come in Thompson
walking slowly
trying to run it but Mike I love the
idea of making sure he's right let's
take him in the back and make sure he's
right and that's exactly where he's
going Marc you can't afford to make
another